on reste dans la culture la culture de
la terre et des vignes c'est la saison
des vendanges et on fait les vendanges
aussi à Saint-Quentin cela fait 19 ans
que les amis du passé des lancours ne
rateraient pour rien au monde ce
rendez-vous Jean flotta et André roche
bonjour vous êtes respectivement le
président Jean flate à flatoau
excusez-moi Jean Jean flateau
excusez-moi j'ai écorché votre nom vous
êtes respectivement le Pr président et
le trésorier de cette association qui
fête cette année ses 25 ans alors on le
disait vous allez faire les vendanges ce
dimanche on peut être surpris dans
l'agglomération de Saint-Quentin où on
est entouré d'immeubles de trouver des
vignes mais il enct on dit des fois que
c'est un village à la campagne pour la
partie qui est située dans le le hameau
d'ID des Mousseau et là sur une ancienne
territoire où il y avait une ferme la
ferme des Mousseau et bien nous avons eu
l'idée de recréer un événement à la fois
festive pédagogique et ludique à savoir
replanter une vigne parce qu'il y en
avait le plus gros vignoble était
l'Île-de-France il y a 100 ans à H
encour avec bien entendu un partenariat
avec la communauté d'agglomération qui
avait mis à disposition le terrain mais
qui a été repris par la commune et puis
nous avons replanté une viine pour
associer les enfants des écoles et leur
présenter la filière la culture de la
Vig et puis pour arriver au vin mais on
pourra le dire plus tard au Jud raisin
surtout Jud raisin
combien y a-t-il de pieds de vigne alors
à hancour on a démarré 10 pieds ensuite
on en a ajouté 30 puis ensuite les
gamins d'une classe de Madame Lucas ont
participé financièrement chacun a payé
un pied de vigne et qu'ils ont planté
mais il y a bien longtemps de cela il y
a une vingtaine d'années
actuellement ils sont revenus puis ils
sont venus pour la plantation et puis
pour vendanger 3 ans plus tard également
et puis là 160 pieds de VI maintenant
depuis on va dire une quinzaine d'années
raisin rouge et raisin blanc alors bonne
question nous avons mis du raisin blanc
un sépage blanc alors sépage noble
chardonnis puis sépage pour être sûr
d'avoir du raisin un hybride blanc or
avec les alléas climatiques cette année
pour ceux qui ont des jardins ils savent
qu'ils ont des problèmes avec les pieds
de tomate avec les courgette je pourrais
continuer avec deux maladies l'ogium et
le midu donc chardon
mais il reste aussi le raisin rouge vous
aviez posé la question qui est un
hybride 54 55 où là comme on avancé les
vendanges il va y avoir quand même
beaucoup de raisins rouges avantanger et
également quelques grabes qui sont pas
trop muris mais les gamins ont vu ce
qu'il fallait vendanger et aussi
certains qui ont été atteints par
l'udium et le Midou mais les gamins sont
venus visiter avant de vendanger
dimanche ils sont venus mardi dernier et
encore ce matin il y a une classe et
donc ce dimanche ils vont vendanger pour
9 fête des vendanges les enfants on
disait sont au première loge puisquils
participent au ramassage et au foulage
du raisin avec les pieds c'est important
de faire participer toutes les
générations André roche oui bien sûr et
c'est surtout important de faire
participer les écoles de deslancour
puisque nous avons 12 classes primaires
je crois et six classes maternelles six
écoles pardon donc c'est très important
que les enfants au moins les enfants
apprennent et et savent maintenant ce
qu'est la vigne puisqu'ils l'ont planté
ils l'ont ils ont cuilli le raisin ils
ont vendangé et après ils ont vu le jus
de raisin sortir du pressoir oui c'est
non seulement un travail pédagogique
mais c'est aussi ludique et puis vous le
disiez festif he puisque c'est la fête
il va y avoir aussi un char qui a été
décoré c'est bien ça alors le en fait
depuis des années la commune nous met à
disposition un camion que nous décorons
le samedi après-midi sous forme de char
et sur lequel vont monter les enfants
après avoir vendanger goûteré le jus de
raisin mais avoir eu un goûter offert
par les Amis du passé en cour et donc
ils descendent au village sur le camion
ils sont très heureux et on rejoint euh
les personnes qui ont participé au
vendange à la cave la musarde où là il y
a les VIP qui sont invités pour
l'apéritif et puis un repas dansant
animé pour mais alors qu'on comprenne
bien le vin le le raisin qui va être
amamassé ce dimanche n'est pas celui
qu'on boira le jour même à la musarde
hein c'est la récolte de l'année
dernière tout à fait et même voire de
l'année d'avant parce que là déjà
l'année dernière nous avions un problème
avec le blanc nous en avons très peu
alors qu'il y a 2 ans voire 3 ans on
avait 60 L de raisin de jus de raisin
qui donnait du vin blanc et environ 120
l de vin rosé parce qu'avec le raisin
noir si on fait pas mal serré enfin il y
a toute une al on a l'impression que
c'est difficile d'entretenir une vigne
comme ça toute l'année malgré l'aide des
élèves oui c'est difficile puisque
effectivement il y a plusieurs maladies
qui apparaissent et on veut disons
sulfater le moins possible mais on est
obligé de le faire parce que sinon on
aurait rien du tout et et effectivement
ce qui fait qu'on a par exemple cette
année bien moins de bien moins de raisin
et donc bien moins de jus voilà et les
enfants ne sont pas trop déçus alors
écoutez on va savoir ça dimanche ils
auront au moins Chac ils auront quand
même du raisin à ramasser parce qu'il y
en a quand même beaucoup certains sont
très mûs d'autres sont à moitié mû et
d'autres sont pas du tout mûs qu'on va
laisser puisque je crois que le
Président vous disait que était en train
de vous dire que l'on va faire
maintenant on va faire autre chose avec
ce jus de raisin étant donné que les
enfants viennent visiter la vigne au
cours de l'année et qu'on ne peut rien
leur offrir le vin c'est quand même un
peu difficile on va donc pasteuriser
pour faire du jus de raisin pouvoir leur
offrir du jus de raisin oui et puis il
doivent être très fier aussi de pouvoir
déguster voilà leur travail hein parce
que on le disait c'est ramassé fouleré
au pied est-ce qu'il y a des étapes qui
sont un petit peu difficiles pour ces
enfants parce qu'ils sont assez assez
petits alors il faut il faut savoir que
le plus petit vigron le plus petit
vendangeur il y a 2 ans il devit avoir
un an on a une photo
assis dans la vigne il commence à manger
les grappes de raisin après dans le
foulage au pied ce sont les jeunes
filles très jeunes qui participent le
plus au foulage al foulage é grarapage
puis après il y a le pressoir après il
boivent le jus de raisin mais pas trop
parce qu'il est sucré sirupeux il y a
déjà un tout petit peu d'alcool alors
comme il a été dit par mon ami Andr
roche le trésorier en fait ils n'ont pas
le droit de boire le vin nous il sera
dégusté nous serons à la fête d'automne
le dernier dimanche avec modétion avec
modération et nous serons sur le
rond-point castina delP en cour et comme
chaque année l'année dernière on a eu
120 personnes qui ont dégusté qui ont
ont donné des appréciations mais il faut
savoir que le but premier c'est faire
vendanger les gamins c'est pas faire du
vin d'ailleurs on n' pas le droit de le
vendre mais on peut donner et faire
déguster oui c'est une association oui
et comme vous avez dit pédagogique là
nous alors l'étape supplémentaire c'est
pasteuriser le jus de raisin mais deux
des amis qui font partie de
l'association qui font un travail
formidable parce que c'est bénévole et
il y a de bonne idée à savoir euh un
document pédagogique sur le cycle la
viine qu'on remet à la maîtresse et au
gamin alors on va parler de votre
association à présent he qui faê ses 25
ans cette année et à cette occasion vous
éditer donc ce livre don je sais pas si
on le voit bien à la caméra qui coûte 10
€ qui est déjà sorti qu'on peut se
procurer auprès de l'association alors
expliquez-nous ce qu'on y trouve on est
trouve tout tout l'historique de
l'association et tout et aussi donc les
les vendanges la balade que l'on fait
chaque année la fête de la Saint-Vincent
qu'on commémore tous les ans beaucoup de
photos de d' il y a beaucoup de photos
effectivement et aussi tous les livres
que l'on a fait qui nous avons fait
trois livres Lean hlancour et son et son
école qui a été éditée en 1980 je vous
en prendre un pour le montrer en de en
2001 dans 2001 ensuite on a fait la
vigne à hencour en 2003 voilà et puis le
dernier qui nous est sorti c'est
hlencour un village devenu ville hm hm
qui est sorti il y a 2 ans celui-ci 5 en
2007 le plus récent pardon en 2007 donc
c'est un vrai travail de de recherche
d'archives d'écriture hein que vous
réalisez pour cette association vous
êtes une quarantaine de membres c'est ça
oui à peu près entre 35 40 ouiou et
quels sont les les projets en cours les
recherches en cours alors concernant les
les recherches nous avions comment
dirais-je le le but ce qui est noté
c'est que nous sommes euh enfin un des
objets c'est faire de la recherche
historique mais pas seulement on vient
de le voir c'est péréniser un événement
or euh à partir euh des archives
municipales en particulier des de l'état
civil nous avions eu connaissance d'un
crash d'avion au cours de la dernière
guerre mondiale 1939- 1944 et là à
partir de cela et un travail ensuite de
fourmis c'est-à-dire essayer de
retrouver et les noms des aviateurs et
leur nationalité et également et pour
commémorer honorer ces personnes en juin
2014 c'est-à-dire 70 ans après et là
effectivement c'est une proposition
notre projet avec la
municipalité vraiment en pleine
recherche ça l'
ass pouir commémorer dites pas tout hein
on dit pas tout qu' faut si on pourrait
t'aider à trouver des familles des
comment dirais-je des aviateurs quand
quand nous les aurons communiquer merci
beaucoup à vous deux d'être venus sur le
plateau pour nous parler de votre
association